serez vous l'année prochaine irlandais
tranquille cary grant new fifties ou
aventuriers du futur ce sont les quatre
styles que les couturiers nous propose à
nous les hommes pour l'hiver prochain
les professionnels du prêt-à-porter
viennent de les présenter au salon
européen de la mode masculine qui vient
de s'ouvrir à paris et hélène risacher y
était les faire son marché à la
recherche de l'homme idéal pour l'année
prochaine voilà l'homme 1985-86 au saut
du lit il ya toujours un problème son
origine son allocation il fallait trois
produits intermédiaires et c'est là
dessus qu'on s'est bagarré alors on a
créé des pyjamas de ville départ et
autres poches d europe de chant franck
et si demain je trouvais le bouton 0 mg
aux maisons baillées de galles
normalement j'ai peu de pantalons et
puis c'est la seule serviette d'après
vin qui ne tombe pas et à propos de
serviettes
que pensez vous de cette cravate
on
en fait la mode 85 c'est un coup
fulgurant pour attraper les filles la
crise
mais quelle crise bien sûr ces messieurs
achètent de moins en moins de vêtements
exception faite des pantalons de sexe
oblige mais quand ils achètent ils
prennent tous le clean débrancher les
attouchements penneteau
mike bryan avocat vous disiez branché
derrière ces écrans se cache l'un des
plus grands couturiers français
une griffe qui suscite les convoitises
et attire les champions du pétrodollar
les hommes de l'arabie saoudite
ils viennent ici dépenser chaque année
entre 600 et 800 mille francs tout en se
plaignant des prix
surnommé par la salle et ils augmentent
les compagnies s'ils augmentent les prix
tandis que le franc
alors gentil jeune homme allez vous
rhabiller
mais quand même pour le plaisir des
dames en voilà un autre
c'est suivant les costards scène et
cravate
et puis comme on les aime vraiment
beaucoup ces hommes de l'année allait
encore une fois bon
vous avez échappé de tout à ce genre de
spectacle avec moi ce qu'on appelle au
théâtre un changement à vue tout cela
pour vous prouver que cette mode de
l'hiver prochain est finalement assez
portables enfin - après tout c'est à
vous d'en juger
c'est un modèle qui représente justement
le style new fifties c'est à dire les
années 50 et il a été créé par l'équipe
de stylistes de vestiaire